the first like one to two hours and then
things will [ __ ] will fall apart and I'm
really relying on you as capable
developers as people experiencing react
to figure out stuff on your own ask
questions as help each other and we're
definitely all gonna finish much today
I just want you to get your feet wet and
understand what is possible so that you
can go figure it out yourself this is
all I can do in three hours so bill
about myself I have done we have for two
years Gatsby for one year briefly
drawing a Gatsby a team working on some
internal stuff and then got a better
offer another Phi but but I think that
Gatsby is a significant innovation in
the react space I think it helps counter
a lot of the problems with react and
people y'all about JavaScript frameworks
being heavy and being having issues with
performance I think this really solves
that just like next years as well but in
a different way and we'll talk a little
bit about why Java stack I think a lot
of people are confused by this term I
was confused even when I joined the
elephant magnify is not the creator of
Java stack but strongly promotes it
because it's a CDN first hosting company
but I'm here I'm not here to talk about
alpha I'm just here to talk about the
idea in general and whether what's the
use cases it suits so okay so so
hopefully everyone has downloaded this
github repo we're about to get started
the first thing I want you to do is to
immediately go to the github repo where
is it
okay so we have notes in a sample site
in the github repo and inside the the
notes this will take a while so I just
want you to get started with it first
there's a welcome page it just lists
some the the the lesson plan for today
as well as some basics that you probably
already have
and then if you go to the first one the
jam into the Jeff stack so I'm gonna ask
you to kick off a build while we talk so
that you can see the whole process start
to finish so I'm gonna just click to
deploy my dimension starter it's going
to link to the amplify console
that's the desta tool that were using
for today hopefully everyone has an AWS
account if not this is where you start
signing in and all that it may require a
credit card I'm not sure but I mean
virtually everyone is this AWS and if
not you can use magnifier now if I does
not create record a credit card but I'm
I'm basing on AWS today so if you if you
log in you get to this flow it's
basically just gonna deploy that that
site that we chose and we're just gonna
click connect to github I'm already
connected you may need to login on your
own
it says github authorization was
successful for me again if you're not
logged in if you're doing this for the
first time you may need to do some
authorization I'm gonna go with the
default name I don't think I have this
default name already and yep and it's
creating my app ok so so I want you to
do that this is the dimension starter
we're also gonna clone overreacted I oh
if everyone knows that's Danny Abramoff
blog from the react core team
I've also gonna clone that let's just do
it so I open that link in in the intro
to jam stack notes is anyone lost rich
again okay with loss okay
what's where where did I lose you
sorry yeah it you you click this you
click this link and it opens to a new
opens a new window and you just follow
the instructions all the way through the
link is in Jam stack Jeff's like jump
start notes 0 1 intro to Jam stack yes
if you don't you can you can choose to
sign up for one or you can try to use
the lfi as well but I won't be teaching
that today I can I can cover that later
on I realized again I realized I should
have put that in the instruction it's
like people should sign up for AWS first
umm so apologies for that I didn't
really them really I I think I just
assumed that people who would have it
okay and if you're if you're lost I try
to ask someone next to you okay so so
I'm just gonna deploy those two sites
there's other sites that you can deploy
as well but I just want to give you the
sense of that's all the work that takes
to start deployment in a gem step world
it really is you're taking that source
code you're copying you cloning it over
and you're pushing into the servers and
it's very it's very light oh the one the
one with overreacted I oh you got to
change the name of it because they don't
allow dots in the name so I'm gonna
clone this again this is this is the
over reactor that I'll clone if you look
at the URL it's too small for you to see
but it's just a github thing that's
that's all the link does so I click
connect to github and instead of that
name I'm gonna change that name to
something else that has no dots in it
things are very slow suddenly is it all
of you guys downloading [ __ ] okay
overreacted I ljs cough whatever just no
dots in the name
I already complained to AWS about the
validation they should validate properly
okay so I join you to get started that
that thing will be building and kicking
off and we'll talk about that later but
now I just need to give you this intro
to gem stack all of you already saw this
don't worry about it
what is Gemstar Jeff stack stands for
JavaScript API is a markup and that's
that's a very silly name right like
every app uses JavaScript API is and
markup in some way why is this such a
big deal and so I want to give you the
context from from where we're coming
from and and may try to make sense of
what what this all is so in the
beginning like the very first web site
was a gem stack site right this is this
is from I think CERN and it was just
vanilla HTML and and just some links and
you could link you can link around and
then we need it more and then I'm just
gonna have more memes because I like
like some presentation stuff and then we
need it more and we started serving
things from an origin server and then we
wanted more dynamic capability so we
wanted to have a program running behind
it to dynamically generate some some
sites so for example I can have a
counter and it shows the current time as
of the time that you visit it should I
be sitting down feel like you can
actually see it so so then we all need
some persistence so we started adding
databases behind us the server so and
that's how you get Wikipedia for example
right but then there's a problem with
this and so the open source stack to all
this it basically became lamp that was a
dominant paradigm from 1990 to 2000
towards the late parts of 2000 so we
started with one more dynamic stuff on
the client-side the front end right so
we started to innovate on the JavaScript
angle notice there was no JavaScript in
any of this right and now there's a
little bit of JavaScript in a
client-side right we started using
mootools jQuery UI UI whatever and and
eventually like we started to run into
problems on it with this stack because
we start to have scaling issues and so
we have to throw in some caching right
at intermediate layers we have different
names for all these caches like radius
or whatever but and then we had
introduced this idea of a CDN we put a
CDN in front of our origin layer a lot
of you have done this in your own setup
and a lot of you just have been worried
about it but these are the kinds of
things that are to be introduced at
scale and you start having all these
problems with monitoring versioning
replication fingerprinting and and even
more like security stuff basically
when you wanna raise money from VCU you
make a deck like this and you put the
text like slightly askew and you say
pain points and this is the other pain
points every song so so basically what
is the pain points you know what's the
origin of all this like this is modern
infrastructure that we build up piece by
piece never really plan for it to all
stick together and what is the source of
it it's really basically the running
server like we have to scale it we have
to manage it it'd be ideal if we don't
so it really was down to security
reliability and complexity which which
is correlated with cost I have a I have
a I have a link actually from this
everyone know who West bosses West boss
is one of the best jazz developers in
the world
he runs a store and when people order
his stickers he could see server crashes
and service lowness you folks totally
crashed my server someone was trying to
subscribe to his course the server crash
so he lost the log in making your own
server is hard he's on his own site for
fours just because he just set it up
wrong like experts get it wrong how can
we make it easier right so that's the
that's the context that we start from
the other thing that started happening
is JavaScript started eating the world
right
we went from John's : on front-end we
had we had all these like it was a toy
language from yes one yes to yes three
and then there was 10 years that we did
nothing there so fun story and then now
it's my way of a yearly cadence and tc39
is actually a pretty serious
organization will smith again okay so so
then we started breaking trying to break
apart so we had frameworks come out of
it we had went from jQuery to like
backbone knockout angular and and then
we also started eating the the we looked
at the backend we said why you know
JavaScript so obviously we started
turning out JavaScript on the back end
popularized by MongoDB with [ __ ]
Express angular and node and so now we
have this full JavaScript landscape by
full stack GS which is like that's kind
of what I like to talk about editor GS
car
like JavaScript slowly if anything can
be rewritten in JavaScript it will be
let's call Edwards law he's one of the
cofounders of Stack Overflow so this
this always fine but we're just
reinventing little parts of like the
lamp stack just like replacing parts of
it with Jas and that's why we have the
myth of the the full stack developer
like having to know everything from
Postgres all the way to CSS so the
problems with but the problems with this
like we've only replace the lamp stack
with like Jas versions of the lamp stack
we haven't really done anything we still
have this we have different logos but we
have the same still caching and security
issues so and and the big one is
performance the the bigger and bigger
Jas bundles on the front end get the the
more the more load it has especially for
mobile users I'm sure everyone here
knows about that the the performance
studies all the scared
scary numbers but my favorite is the 4%
of mobile users to throw their phones
while waiting and being super super
frustrated yeah I value but I have a
very thick case on my phone so it's very
dropped proof but yeah I can probably
show it if I want to the according to
Alex Russell wanted on the google chrome
dev rails the ideal budget for your for
your first load should be a hundred and
thirty two hundred seventy GB of
critical critical path resources let's
just call it all JavaScript react alone
is 30 40 KB and you throw in a whole
bunch of dependencies that you typically
put in you typically busting 200 before
because it they care about parsing time
as well that's the time that interactive
it all comes in there will have a house
on charts as well so so this is
literally doing the math if if like on a
3G network you want to have a five
second load you work you work backwards
on the under transfer rates these set a
budget of 130 to 170 I recommend his
blog post is a pretty good read on where
you need to be in terms of performance
budgets conversely this is a log of
general JavaScript bundles overall we we
passed that
370 KB mark in 2011 we're currently now
at 400 KB for the median desktop and
mobile bundle and that's that's those
those are the sort of like the fat
JavaScript bundle like when react
scripts what reactions does is just it
generates a Fat Joe scale bundle for you
right that's a little bit code splitting
but that's it so it would be nice to
improve the performance and the time
very interactive up there and so and so
this is this is kind of the the
performance issues that that we we start
dealing with like we have the initial
request this is the original nice-nice
request and then we have all this like
fat JavaScript and that really blocks
that the more requests you have they
really blocks the time to be able to
render this so if we if we could just
render everything that we have with the
original HTML request and slowly load
the JavaScript we'd be able to rapidly
increase the time interactive by default
create react that gives you empty div
it's just a blank white page that's not
very good for SEO and not very good for
performance as well because everything
is just stuffed in your JavaScript all
everything that you write so that's
that's the client-side rendering
paradigm this is kind of the chart where
you have your get you you send you get
request you get the bundle back and
you're rendering this is all blocking
and therefore your tender and
interactive is very far out FCP is first
content for pain so as opposed to
server-side rendering why a lot of
people move to next j/s it's because you
just have the get request they render on
a server and then they send you the
server-side rendered HTML and therefore
there's no client-side rendering to be
executed before your site is interactive
so so the mean stack actually were sent
from the lamp stack in terms of it has
the same issues as security reliability
complexity and cost and then it added a
performance thing on the front end not
great not great it's very good news for
JavaScript engineers because then we're
just like employed everywhere which is
really nice
so there's a spectrum but I think those
are not the only two choices and that's
what we are all here to learn there's
the full client-side rendering on the on
one end and then there's full server
side rendering on the other end
there's a space in the middle to do
other stuff so we'll talk about that
that try this from Google by the way
meanwhile all this is going on I've just
told the story of the past 20-something
years
meanwhile all this is going on other
stuff is happening in development
ecosystem as well the API economy Rose
as well so these are all companies that
don't have direct customers they're
their customers are you guys and they're
massively successful and they just exist
to make parts of your life easier that
you don't you shouldn't be writing your
own stripe in a gray [ __ ] I mean you
shouldn't be already own payments
channel right you should not be my
favorite is plaid a lot of people don't
know here don't know Claire but plaid
basically integrates with all banks in
the US I don't know if they're in Europe
as well but basically if you want to
deduct money to like start a startup
like a Robin Hood you just integrate
your plan and immediately your customers
can just send you money from their bank
accounts it's amazing this is stuff that
you don't want to build yourself so all
these ApS are just available for you to
interact with so then it's like okay
that the jobs of a back-end developer of
a developer is increasingly decreased
like the undifferentiated stuff you
don't have to do the stuff that really
makes your company stand out your
projects and out that's the stuff you
should be focusing on and just pay these
guys to do the rest because they're just
specialists at it the other trend
serverless launched in 2014 by AWS
lambda but there is also a Google App
Engine before that and quickly cloned by
the other two big giants Google and
Amazon and Microsoft
so that's GCP and that's as your other
way around everyone started using get 10
years ago people get wasn't a normal
thing so so we wanted to take advantage
of all of this to like try to try to see
like what all these trends are everybody
started using build tools we went from
an age of just including scripts in to
actually putting these things in our
build processes and and it's part of our
CI NCD process anyone know let's play
obviously this is our favorite over here
what's what's this on
right rolled up okay
what's this you know yes lens very nice
this one it's the challenging one so
this is Google closure compiler it's the
one that face react actually uses to
compile some source code to to actually
deliverable so so then we then nullify
we started looking at all these static
site generators as well it's a rising
trend of basically build tools coupled
with getting workflow coupled with all
these other stuff and and we realized
something that was very non consensus at
the time which is static site generators
at a next big thing like it's rising and
people are actually using it for to do
some pretty interesting stuff especially
with the new generation of static site
generators like like Gatsby
you're not just generating static HTML
like Jekyll
Hugo those are the first generation just
generating static HTML that's it you're
done with Gatsby you're you're
generating HTML sending it and then
you're also generating a journey in j/s
bundle and rehydrating it so it becomes
a becomes an app we use static gender
comm to track all these static
generators and it takes advantage of
this this new generation I just I just
jumped ahead of myself I'm sorry over
there a lot of people don't know what
rehydration is rehydration is so this
process of like we switch around the
client side app thing so we have the
initial request and we when we send the
HTML it already looks like that like
there's a shell of like everything
that's pre-rendered like it's the the
perceived performance the perceived
loading is superfast view painted it can
be Oh actually yeah so this is still
HTML view preview painting and then
javascript by the time the javascript
bundle arrives it can actually become a
dynamically loaded app this ER there's
an uncanny valley here where javascript
is taking over and rehydrating all the
elements on the HTML and that's a
problem that google is actively working
with the two main with gatsby and next
year's to solve this which is the
uncanny valley most of us don't care
about this detail performance because
it's on the order of hundreds of
microseconds milliseconds so anyway just
to tie it all up all these trends get
workflow build tools server let's API
economy static sites
that is the gem sack that is that is
that's that's what enables the Jeff Zack
now versus twenty years ago so the focus
is really on user experience like we
just want to send Markham and JavaScript
to your user you ping api's if you need
to to generate that markup and but then
once the bundle wants the app is on the
user side you just interact with api's
on your own with javascript there's no
there's no running server to interactive
the the best parallel like I can I can
say about this is basically mobile
phones like mobile apps like mobile apps
are all static assets but there no one
accuses them of being static they're all
dynamic is it then I make you see one
will sniff again and then and that kind
of follows the purple pattern like
push-pull I actually don't don't really
know that what the PRP L stands for but
these are all like best practices as a
court according to Google I honestly
don't care enough I just I'm just like
you just like you're not going to code
you're gonna call all this by yourself
you just want to use a framework that
does it for you and that's what Gaspee
does best way but by the way that's
that's why their theme their color theme
is purple so in a comparison of all the
rendering rendering paradigms static
site static rendering is the easiest
because you do all the work upfront
ahead of time and when you when the
request comes in you just send HTML
where server-side rendering is a little
bit slower because you do the work on
request when you when you send a request
work is done and then and then then
render comes to you and obviously
client-side rendering so slowest so
that's the that's the full spectrum I
honestly I recommend this so I this blog
post by addy Osmani again rendering on
the web
he goes into a lot more detail about how
you can achieve I can pick the right
level of dynamism for your project and
your performance needs and I liked I
liked I liked talking about what is Jen
saying what is not just X so you can
understand these are Jeff static static
hosts so natla files on there as well
and an amplified console so s3 bucket
github pages these are what is not gem
stack is like WordPress Drupal
and it's like running server or
server-side oriented things yeah I could
probably do this lite better
I should put in on Jeff side the
original Jeff's like site this is still
up I have this romantic idea of the
unbreakable web like the the website way
you don't have to keep a running server
around this is the original Space Jam
website and it's still around it's been
around 20 years he'll be around for many
more because it's just static assets and
we can keep that forever and so so
that's that's the rough intro I think I
think I think I don't have that much
time to skip ahead there's a there's a
trend also of headless EMS those of you
who work for agencies will be very
familiar with the so this the rough set
up which is when we're building we use
we use get to commit to push to the
tourists through a static site host and
we can pull in from Hitler CMS's or
whatever content sources we want they
can be markdown files that can be api's
that we run or someone that we hire to
do that so hey this wordpress hit ghost
is a major CMS as well contentful some
of you have used it I think you Scoob
you know these are all like very very
focused on agency use cases like if you
need to set up a site for a
non-technical user to start editing
content and you're the developer that
you're contracted as a freelancer or
something and then you hand it off I
think this is really good or if you just
like for me personally I can I can do
all my content on air table and it just
pulls in from your table as well so I
really like all that and it's it's all
it's all collected on a CMS where Gatsby
comes in is gasps me regards this as all
the content mesh this is their word for
it again their blog posts journey to the
content mesh is is their VC pitch
basically like why what is going on in
terms of like why is this an investable
trend and basically saying like all
these content systems will ingest it
into graph QL
will run it through our react server or
build tool and then we'll push it out to
static hosting which is notify amplify
all this
Hosting so that's the that's the rough
idea this is this is Brendan Eich he
always says always bet on JavaScript so
I've sort of taken his quote and just
made it into always bet on gem stack so
that's the that's the rough intro to gem
stack like why it's wiser tray and why
people care about it why why it's such a
big deal even though and I in fact i
think javascript api is are the most
boring parts of gem stack actually
marked us the more interesting thing
because markup is no longer static
markup
it's markup that that's being run on the
server and then again on the client and
that's exactly what gatsby does so so I
think now we're at a point where so so
we just finished the intro to gem stack
piece you can have more reading over
here I have more information and links I
I really like Chris coiours talk about
the all-powerful front-end developer
basically the more you can do server
Leslie the less you the less you need to
do on the server on the server side and
therefore the more you can do as a
front-end developer as a product
developer is suggestive okay so I really
like that okay so what I'm gonna have
everyone do now is check their amplify
console so everything should have
deployed already and if you see over
here in my in my console when we started
this session you should already have had
this deployed this is more or less
everyone sees the same page and when you
click on this you can actually see the
deployed site it's at it's at some
random hash and it's something dot
amplify app comm something like that
yeah
cool now I'm also going to go over to my
overreacted IO clone again that that is
the same thing I've cloned Danny bro
mom's blog just by clicking a few
buttons right so like the potential to
jam stack is that you're just everything
is get based and you can if it's open
source you can fork it and you can
deploy it very easily it cost you
nothing and now the main thing I want
you to do is it not just cloned it also
force it to your github that's why you
have to get hub connection so over down
here there's a there's a link to your
github so if you click over there it
links to that that fork of your github
that you're that they created for you
and now you can change anything in in
the content so let's say I'm going to
change where's the content source pages
in this is the overreacted Iowa source
and this is a Gatsby site by the way
everything we're cloning is a Gatsby
site let's say I want to change the
title of this blog post name it name it
and they will come I'm just gonna change
it over here index dot MD change it and
say hello JS Kampf Asia noticed I'm
working entirely inside of github so
what this what this is doing right now
is I just committed that change to get
right you can do the same thing for the
Gatsby started dimension as well you can
change your markdown files you can
change JavaScript doesn't matter what
what this actually does is that it will
start a kick off that build
right so so and this is the this the
process it starts to provision a
billboard for you basically like a build
server it will build it will run gasps
rebuild on your on your project it'll do
for your site and you'll verify by
checking by taking some screenshots if
you go back to the build history you can
see our original build this this build
is just kicked off based on my updating
of my markdown file but if you go back
to the original bill you can see the
entire process provision cloning
repository blah blah blah there's no
back end because I didn't put it back in
but but they also verify by generating
all these screenshots so you can see
that you've you you're deploying what
you expect yeah this is my clone of or
overreacted I oh didn't take very much
and that's a potential jump stack I
think that if everything is good based
that's the ultimate version control for
both your app as well as your content
and both can go in step with each other
which is very nice okay so yeah that's
the that's the first piece I would just
want to pause you and ask if this if
there's anyone with questions if they're
lost I've been talking for a bit no okay
all right so now we're going to go to
the intro to Gatsby part because now you
have you have two Gatsby sites you have
this site with it which is the started I
mentioned site and this was created for
you by by just by clicking that button
right you have the overreacted i/o site
and this was created for you again like
that these are examples or more
complicated overreacted IO is very
complicated
there are Gatsby known has like 200
lines of just configuration and and I'm
gonna teach you how to read all this
that's the that's the hard part
what we're gonna do now is we're gonna
go to do to go to part 2 which is the
intro to Gatsby okay so this one I don't
have slides but I just have a rough idea
well so what does Gatsby Gatsby is a
site for creating websites to be ah yes
okay so I just wanna I'm just going to
switch over to the
thing here ok so what's important about
knowing nothing to know about Gatsby so
gas retakes content like also the
content that's just let's just have
different kinds of content so that's
just that like images JSON files
markdown some API requests for example
if you want to run a shop a shop on
Gatsby you can have a campaign the
Shopify API asked what's available and
feed that in so all of these become
nodes
I'm gonna show you how to do that in a
minute all these become notes some of
them need to be transformed so an image
may need to be transformed into for
resizing for optimal image compression
so like better image
that's what JSON it doesn't need any
transform so it just goes straight to
markdown needs transformations from
markdown into HTML based on markdown so
you have a remark transformer
transformer API is also you're fine you
may need to log in and have some
authentication here but basically the
idea is to take all these nodes and wrap
them up into a single graphical layer
and then from the graphical everything
is fungible everything is kind of
requestable from each other you can have
pages so the this slash pages folder is
a special magic folder inside of this
every every single page like about a s
index is every single page can make a
graphical request to request any single
one of these things so we're using graph
kill as a unified data layer right
we've type checking and you can
prototype the data as well that you get
from this and so there's there's this
guy and then there's gatsby no js' so
pages are just by convention it would
just run through everything for you but
anything else that is that is not a
standard page for example if I have a
whole bunch of markdown files I'm not
gonna specify all right day one is day
to day is day three Dodgers they're
stupid
instead I'm going to have a template
they template
jas inside of my gat 3-node I'm gonna
say take all these markdown files and
run it through gas PJs and
programmatically generate page one two
three four five as many as I want
same thing for images anything for JSON
basically standard format for for
consuming all this coming into here
graph QL and then this is all react
right you're requesting it so it does
one server-side render into index into
HTML as well as a whole bunch of
different JavaScript bundles sorry so
there's a there's a lot of different
HTML as well so every single route has
its own HTML folder so if you turn
JavaScript off if your if your SEO is if
your search engine doesn't run your
JavaScript is fine because you can read
everything on your page
but then it also generates the
JavaScript bundles so that on the
client-side it rehydrates into a full
single page app so as you navigate from
index to about it no longer across the
HTML because it's just because the
remaining data that it needs okay so
hopefully that was like the first time I
ever did that but am I missing anything
no I think I would just show you okay so
so so this is the exercise that I'm
gonna hopefully get you to start I hope
I hope it won't go off the rails that
quickly uh-huh but we'll see so so the
repo I have you I have the I had you
clone has notes right and that's the
thing that you've been reading but it
also has a site so over on the site I
think I've left I left i filled in quite
a lot of stuff but I want you to be able
to fill the fill stuff in yourself if
you if you npm install the dependencies
inside of sites actually i'm just gonna
go ahead
sorry
no I think I I think I hear so I want to
do was I had a get subtree I buy sit in
so I just need to remove get get in it
get in
sorry sorry about that I I wasn't hiding
things from you on purpose okay so if
you get pull again it's get full force
it should be
yep I see I see the site on my on this
site now okay cool so so we're not going
to go to the data stuff and I left
that's just nuke let's just go into
slash paid sword slash pages can
everyone see this oh this is dark okay
color theme light much better right okay
so we're just gonna nuke all this this
entire thing so I mean source slash
index is sloshed source /pages slash and
I'm just gonna have this simple thing
here saying page one and that's and
that's that's that's all the commitment
that that's all I need to do to to get
this started so make sure to install NPM
install so that all the dependencies are
installed as well sorry I'm not very
well organized but all right I'm gonna
run you're gonna start and kick that off
the main thing that runs is Gatsby
develop now it's compiling all the pages
and and so we can see ooh ah
hang on I have a spare page
okay okay it looks like it looks like I
committed something that I should not
have so I think if you just if you just
name this site title query - it should
be fine inside off layout see I'll try
to like save all the work that you need
to do unfortunately I don't think I did
it very well
I'm gonna I'm gonna commit this again as
well so you can just pull fix okay so my
index dot HTML has this has this page
one can everybody get here oh I'm so
sorry
why don't we watch some YouTube
questions on this does this make sense
no Gatsby comes with it in fact it's a
it's a it's a pro and a con the pro is
that everything has a standard data
there and you can prototype very easily
the con is that it takes a lot of spin
up so it's a bit slower but I think you
trade the upfront power are you trained
the upfront startup time for overall
power
I'll show you yeah it's a it's a request
so I know people have npm installing I'm
not really sure what to cover now let's
see yeah okay okay I'm sorry about that
just keep it yeah
yeah I mean I've just I've just been
instructed to use a ittle guess for this
tool but then there's there's other
static cycles that you can use as well
okay so I just want to give you the idea
that just by convention anything inside
the pages anything with a JavaScript
file it is and has an export default is
it is a page that you can you can start
rendering so it's a little bit like next
year as well like that's magic pages
folder and it's and it's different from
react scripts because react scripts
doesn't have anything right by default
so this sets our routing for you as well
as code splitting every single page is
code split it based on bits on the page
boundaries so let's set up a different
page like about Jas and I'm gonna import
react as well or I can write my own
expert default function you turn each
one about page so so that's it I just
created that J's file I created the
about page I think in recompile so I
didn't don't even have to restart the
server and now if I go to localhost 8080
right so very like you didn't even set
up routing which is fantastic although
although you probably need to put links
between them one thing I'd like to show
people that stuff is being statically
rendered is in the network tab when i
refresh I get an about dot HTML this is
an HTML document
oh I've actually not surface I rendered
this okay so so in development this
doesn't work about in production you
actually will see inside the preview of
the the pre rendered page which is
pretty cool and to prove that it's just
HTML no yes okay and if you type any
random characters inside it and just
like get a 404 page Oh
I'm sorry I have screwed this up as well
okay yeah but it gives you a development
404 page with with all the darts of all
the pages that you've created so that's
that's the that's the rough idea okay so
I'm gonna leave you to it right now in
terms of the exercises so where we are
now is intro to Gatsby we're making
pages and we're gonna make a component
layout component this is pure react you
make a you make a folder call it
whatever the hell you want make a file
call it whatever how do you want make a
layout component that renders children
and you import that into your page and
we use that code and layout components
very useful to have consistently else
between your pages right right now I
don't have any consistency between my
page pages what if I made a react
component imported it from there and
then used it in both both pages so I
would like you to do that and just get
familiar with the development flow and
look at the rest of the if you're if
you're slightly ahead of the rest of us
look at the rest of the the docs as well
well I'll show you one thing is offer
for those part those people who had the
graphic over there
so localhost 8100 graph duo this is
where the graphical layer is where you
can start querying all the pages so here
I think we have site page you can just
google you can just look around as to
like what the nodes are you can see what
what I talked about like right now we're
consuming JavaScript files and it's
sending out pages so these are these are
pretty helpful
honestly I don't I don't I don't
navigate around these a lot just cuz I
know I don't need it but it's pretty
helpful for figuring out graphical
we're psyched title yeah I want to I
want to it I want to query site metadata
okay so the place the query is site dot
site metadata I'm gonna query all of
this other stuff see if I can get
anything by the way this Explorer on the
left is a new addition to the graph your
ecosystem it was done by my friend Sean
girl that one graph and it's usually
used to have to type who has time for
that right so I think the the wait
request site motivator I'm not sure I'm
not sure I'm doing this right hang on
yeah okay so if I request title
description off author anything I can I
can see I can start seeing my site
metadata so this is configured inside of
Gatsby - config yes this is the starting
point for all Gatsby projects all gasp
we projects must have I guess we can
figure out yes this is your this is
where you pass in any data it's a three
for JSON object you can pass in whatever
you want
guess we in first the types here I've
only pass strings where you can put
numbers or arrays whatever and it and in
first the types and you can start
querying it from your graph QL and so
where that is starting to become
interesting is inside of your pages so
let's say inside of my page and this is
super annoying I'm gonna get rid of it
inside of my page inside of index dot GS
I want to request I want to I want to
use my site metadata so I'm gonna use
site data what it was my instructions I
need to check my own instructions you
just add a query ok so let's say I use
static query and I'm gonna use static
query inside of here data equals sorry
I'm talking too much but okay and then
I'm just gonna render it out over here
I do need to wrap in a graphical tag
good spot yeah
okay so let's see what's see what's
going on in my site localhost:8080
regular expressions flag okay cool so so
I can now use graph key law inside of my
page to request something that is at the
site level because I've consumed all
that inference on information into my
graph I request it pass it into index.js
because I'm using that graph fuel as a
graphical query as a static query and
it's only feed into my statically
rendered site so so I did this on my
index ah yes I want you to do it on the
layout follow the instructions inside
the inside the markdown file over here I
think I think I've been very explicit
about what to do
so yeah well we'll just do this for the
next half hour and then I'll start back
up at 2:30 okay all right yeah and just
mess around and just and there's extra
homework if you want at the bottom the
exercise is as well as the SEO component
how's that
I just talked for one hour
[Applause]
you know just wondering um I didn't
catch fully what your experience was
there you said that you tried I'll get
to be get some reservations about it
is there anything kanessa yeah
basically anything relying on window
method Sonoma yeah that meant also for
some reason I get the component day long
when it shouldn't be called okay we saw
regular reactive it wouldn't be called
yeah $0.25 component it updates you
should have been called a show recently
gas been some things like that sometimes
happens there's so many things that it's
fun so what is the source of yeah and
this is the problem that I think Kathy
Gatsby
similar problems with our next Jas or we
can see if you want to have Spain on the
cruise dynamically loaded condiment
something like coordinates for example
if you write a love potion stuff in them
and you want it to be you don't want to
have a static pages page for all your
tutorials want them to be dynamically
generated if you want to have static you
have I haven't run into this life cycle
thing the main ways I run into problems
is is anything that I know when to open
the method so it just please make sure
that throughout that I always export it
into a dedicated module ancient windows
exists it's not something to like a
different kind of lame a downer stuff
like roots the life cycle a weird stuff
and I don't know why
that's just mine okay you know father
issues all that it is it's it is
early-stage tech and since that year's
actually not that much how much do you
think they got three million and they
hire 35 people it's a lot I don't I
don't represent them
I'm just well they're building like a
preview platform and other enterprise
services so it's not all developers
is everything okay
of whatever
hello okay that's all timer if you ever
need a timer just google countdown timer
and google build it right in for you
it's pretty nice and the music station
is free coke AM radio okay cool
sorry about that
so again I don't expect everyone to have
done everything but I just at least you
get your hands dirty writing your own
Gatsby stuff and we're just gonna plow
right on just we don't have that much
time I'm a little bit behind but I think
I'm okay
so just just so just so you're aware
where we are I'm inside the the repo and
we're in part three now Gatsby plugins
okay I think that gets me plugins so
it's possible to use Gatsby based on the
starters that you choose you can use a
whole bunch of starters here's the
starter library it's gas vgs thought org
slash starters you can get started just
by cloning anything one of these things
click the github you've already been
through the process pulling it down to
your repo change a few files all done
for you 200 start if some of them are
not so high quality so just so fun fact
I actually made this I made this real
case and I was very insistent on the
fact that I could filter by use case so
for example if I want to search for
e-commerce starter this shows me how to
use gas we will Shopify and stripe if I
wants authentication
this has firebase authentication AWS
simplify authentication this is my
personal one gems like a coupon starter
basically you know look through the use
cases there's a lot of different things
it's as flexible as JavaScript can be
but starters are just repos that you
clone and then once you clone it it's
you're you're on your own right
no one's going to maintain your stuff
for you plugins are a pretty bundled set
of capabilities and that's where the
plugins library is it's gasps vgs dot
org slash plugins you have a whole bunch
of them a lot of them are like it's not
very clear why you would use them I
think in if there's one problem in our
industry in general is that we don't
write enough documentation so so if you
can help with the docs it's always it's
always a good idea but also I also made
this thing it's linked see see started
using this so you can link back to the
startup page and filter by starters that
use that thing so you can if you might
be doing a documentation you can use you
can see working examples that use it
which is kind of good enough okay so
there's a lot of different plugins all
of them do vaguely different things
based on the api's that are available to
get to Gatsby so the the main one that
we're going to start dealing with is gas
resource file system guess what as
fascism looks through or your folder
that you give it and it ingests
everything inside it as a node it's very
dumb that's it it has no idea like it
like maybe knows like based on the
extension what file type it is that's it
it's not going to say it's gonna take in
a markdown file and you're just gonna
say alright this note is of type
markdown but it's not gonna convert it
to HTML for you you have to do that on
your own it's not gonna convert it's
gonna convert it it's not gonna convert
to like j/s or whatever so I'm gonna
process the images for you it's just
gonna say alright I have a path to that
image that's it
so I have the source plugin
there will be a lot of remember remember
what I said about the API economy that
all these services with API is out there
that you want to access there's a lot of
plugins there's 990 something 908 plug
plugins and I think this is actually a
big source of power for Gatsby because
every plugin that someone else writes is
immediately code that you can use it's a
network effect of all the different data
sources that that can come into your app
so whatever whatever it is
you're then going to want to transform
them so there's this source plugin and
then there's a transform and there's
there's other smaller types of plugins
and fun fact plugins can have plugins so
even inside of this plug-in I can have
my little children plugins and this is
and and that's just that's just because
how big markdown is so imagine writing a
markdown folder and you put in a URL of
a tweet and it just generates that tweet
component for you
that's a plug-in that's the OEM bid
plug-in and and and you know and all
sorts of and all sorts of things so
basically the the main the main area you
search is here the naming syntax is not
enforced so some of them can be named
something else but they actually doing
that job I'm I've complained to them
about that I think that they should fix
that but basically let's let's just kind
of go through the plugin material so so
yeah so earlier earlier we already I'm
just gonna go in here so earlier already
familiarize ourselves with the site
metadata it's just a JSON blob that we
can request our title from our site
title from but now we're going to
concern ourselves with the plugins array
inside of here right now it's empty I
think yeah I've just left it empty as a
comment field we're going to start using
gas resource file system so the syntax
of plugins if you're using it without
options it's just a string here I have
gatsby plug-in here it doesn't really
matter so that's very simple and it's
nice to see a whole bunch of strings but
once you need to start to apply once you
need to supply options that's where you
get to start this pretty ugly syntax
where it's like resolved and then the
plug-in name and then options and then
it's an arbitrary JSON again of whatever
you want to pass in this looks like this
looks ugly but it's very expressive
because you can use JavaScript to create
the objects however way you like you can
combine it in different ways you can
fetch data from somewhere else and pull
it in it's really up to you how you want
to
create these options so it's maximum
expressiveness so so what I'm gonna do
and demo for you here is to implement
the gas resource file system plugin
we've already npm installed it most most
ghastly setups will have it installed
but just double check in case you get a
unrecognized error so over here I have a
guest resource file system
it's consits I'm teaching it to consume
one of the folders right here I have
some sample content inside of source
slash inside of slash content I have my
first post this is marked down this
thing at the top is front matter that's
metadata for your posts that's data
about your host that's my second post so
I wonder if it's consume stuff so I'm
gonna get it to consume it I'm gonna
give it a name like content I'm gonna
give it a path I don't need this path
that join because I can just use their
name and I'm gonna say a Content dirty
name is an OGS concept I think a lot of
people know but I wasn't I wasn't that
clear so their name is just the kernel
working directory of the the folder you
are running this this process form right
so so Karl my carnal working directory
is Jeff's tech jumpstart slash site
that's my that's my current working
directory so when I when I say your name
I have their name slash content that is
going to be site / content and
everything inside this folder is going
to be markdown files that is consumed
right so so I have that I have that set
up and that's why that's our first
plugin and if I want to go and start
again which is Gatsby develop under the
hood we're going to see in our graphical
we're gonna see no graphical new notes
remember what I said about notes these
are all notes in this case it's a file
that's what that's what the source plug
in as for you it has an ID but it also
has absolute path let's just do the path
relative path over so you can see over
here that now Gatsby has a sense of what
my what my files are I can add in a
third post it's just really bang it over
the head with this one because I think
this is one this is where people start
to shape up because it's no longer just
j/s it's understanding the API so Gatsby
I don't know if it harvey loads I hope
so
hey Harvey loads ok so so pretty clear
right so now we have to take this and
then we have to transform it so that's
the next part of my thing styling a same
thing you need to do server-side
rendering it takes advantage of other
stuff we're just gonna skip that because
I don't have time but definitely try to
practice it because that avoids the
flash of unstyled content that you get
with CSS NGS right if you want to use
something CSS guess like style
components you want to definitely
server-side render that styling so we
explain source plugins already this
gives you an idea of what else plugins
you can get I just went through this
exercise I'm sorry ok so now we're gonna
transform the source the markdown files
right like here we know here we know
they're they're markdown files we're
gonna transform them with Gatsby
transform a remark that's still where
the hell is my okay so we're just we
don't need options we're just gonna
stick it in there so it's going to be in
just in here order does matter so you
want a place you want to place the thing
that works on the previous thing after
the thing you know what I mean we mark
itself has has extra plugins and options
go definitely go read those things
because it's very very useful for your
content writing especially if you're
writing a pretty dynamic content
my personal my personal project is I
want to embed YouTube in like I want to
put a youtube link and it just inflates
into a nice YouTube logo inside of my
markdown which is pretty cool
the last JSI right the better right yes
it should only be for a dynamic custom
stuff but if it's just straight content
let's just leave it all to markdown so I
have guess we transform every mark and
and now I have to do the thing where I
say okay everything is in graphical I'm
gonna show I'm gonna show that later but
now I have to do the thing where I say I
have a template for all the markdown and
I'm gonna programmatically generate for
each file my timer timer down run it
through the template and generate that
HTML every time let's actually show you
the markdown so look here there's
there's only all they're actually off
our off-site page it's very small so you
can see it but okay so no mention of our
markdown right when I killed it and
refresh it it should because now I have
the plugins
I need to reinstall it what its name
okay well you're gonna have to reinstall
it as well because I didn't I didn't
include it I thought I did
oh okay my bed yeah you have to install
the dependency gatsby transformer we
market that's that's just because I left
it out
okay so if i refresh this now you can
see inside of my graphical I have this
new thing called all markdown remark
which is an honest super intuitive name
but it's good enough where we can start
seeing the content that we add added in
so here first post second post their
posts now it's not just a file path
right now I'm reading the file and
parsing it into these things which guess
what it's I can query from graph Q all
inside of my react components you've
already started to do that a little bit
on the site level now we are doing it on
the content level so what we need to do
is we need to we need to basically do
this query do this all Mart Darby
mercury get this array of nodes and then
for each node we will pass this into our
our template as props the props will do
whatever you want with them right you
just render a JSX and then that will be
your your generated page okay to do that
oh [ __ ] my computer died no I might okay
this is this is showing but okay all
right sorry
so to do that I'm going to walk you
through it I'm being extra careful with
this because this is where people really
screw up so so I'm gonna I'm just gonna
use this default template that I put in
my own notes it's pretty much gonna be
exactly the same
actually I think I already provided it
source templates oh no I don't have it
so I'm gonna make it a page template GS
and here I'm gonna paste it in there it
should be pretty much yeah exactly that
okay so that's inside my sword slash
templates folder just be very aware of
what what folder were working in we have
some people with issues earlier so
inside of Gath we know no GS we're gonna
create pages programmatically I'll copy
and paste this in and then I'll explain
what the code does
okay so that what I copied from from our
notes should be the only thing that is
in Kathleen ojs even though I left some
comments in there for future stuff okay
so what does it do this uses this has
here we're using an own API remember
we're doing server-side rendering in
known that's why you have this weird
exports dot syntax we saying create
create pages it's I guess it's gonna
pass to us there Redux actions
gastly internally has all of its
operations done via redux as well as a
graphical helper to to transform
graphical requests okay then we're gonna
get the page template the one that we
just created right that's just your J s
react component then we're going to
we're going to return a promise the
promise is graph QL is a graphical query
it's exactly what we just query just now
all right don't be mark it has some
optional fields that feels don't really
matter probably the one that does matter
is that you want to sort by date so it's
all defined here you can play around
with if you're not sure what it is right
you can go over here and you can say
like date sorry all more dumb remark
sort fields what is the date
they order ascending so so what what
graphical is right is is a way for you
to prototype this exact query and you
literally just copy and paste into here
make sense okay so if you need anything
else if you need any other changes just
study that understand the API if you
need Docs is over here this is standard
graphical stuff again I don't have time
to cover that and this is probably
overkill because all auto-generated but
there's something in there that's gonna
be pretty helpful personally I like to
learn by just seeing what other people
do so I just study other source codes
but it is very very expressive and
powerful because the amount that you
have to code is just very very minimal
you're just using tools which is very
nice I think as coders which is we
should try to do as little coding as we
want as we can so then the last part is
very simple right
we dot then on the promise so now we get
all the results of the graphical query
right assuming has no errors we're gonna
say result data are marked on the edges
stop for each that's the for each that
we wanted right so for each node each
notice is this thing right for each node
we have frontmatter date format it up
slug fermented Oh tags
we're just gonna pass that in as as a
slug for example and actually I should
pass in more information than that yeah
I might regret this but anyway so so
there was never specify page template
that's the thing that we that we that we
resolved earlier in not just with the
net result that we're passing in
everything to page template and we have
this prop called data and now and so so
so now we've we've generated each page
and each page will be called first post
second post their posts and all we need
has been the path that the slug of these
things inside the page we'll do another
query this is this is inside page
template is we do another query this is
a page query you export Const page query
that's a static
typically in the inner page you have
like a default export default right
that's that's your that's what the page
is if you want to have a page level
query you just export page query that's
the magic variable that that gets me
looks for and you and you do whatever
query that you need so the incoming
variable is the path like I know my path
right now all right I'm gonna query for
all the things that match my path and I
need all this on this variable all this
data so what we're going to do I hope
that was right I see some errors so I
might have some copy-paste errors yeah I
think I have call P Pacers or may have
slug
let's see
yeah okay so so I think I have a I think
I have a bug in here in my in my own in
my own code
we'll see what see what that is so I
guess showing debugging is helpful so
I'm gonna take a look at this pipe I'm
clearly specifying something wrong on
the type so I'm just gonna look for this
type and it says title slug date or tags
so I actually means slug I did not mean
path so the way to fix it is to show the
page template and instead of half I'm
just gonna say slug this should be also
slug I think this is also slug
you already fix it for me uh-huh hey
okay so let's look let's look at the 404
page assuming my for my former page is
still okay what whatever your vit I
don't know what screwed up with my 4
page I don't have time to look to fix it
but yours yours should work let me let
me try and refresh this and have a look
no don't leave I should I swear I
promise I said I'm good at this ok you
know what I don't care anymore like I'm
gonna I'm gonna what I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna yarn build and I'm gonna show
you that build result ah oh did I mean
date
what is this markdown remote fun better
I think I think I skipped something 8:10
what did I do what's it
oh they should be slug ah alright run
the build um yeah this is this is
something I don't enjoy about working
this low level you do you do run into a
lot of debugging and you need to know
what's going on but that's that makes
that makes the future a lot brighter
actually right so I think the path
variable has to be named path because I
named it path here
cannot be properly for a matter of no I
see some markdown Lamarckism no what
would happy no I'm not sure okay I'm not
sure I'm not sure about this this build
anymore I'm sorry that's just let's just
try to get it running on the under dev
server and then I'll fix the the
production build cool second post
alright so so my data my data is off how
would how would fix this is just the
console log yet because because I'm
expecting something which doesn't seem
to be there
so my data object is has data and its
markdown remark on now so so something
in my query is not working it's not
right
so how would debug this is I'll go in my
page template go over here I think this
is it
I need my path variable if you spot
anything I'm doing wrong on them you
know first first yeah I have my first
post okay so so right now I'm trying to
debug like why am i markdown is my
markdown remark here my margin remark
here is no and I and I don't expect that
to happen basically because I think
something is not matching correctly
[Music]
therefore I need to figure this out so
so if all this is correct this query
works that means I'm not getting the the
path query that I that I want I suspect
this because I'm not getting this page
I'm so sorry guys
let me just ninja a ninja debug okay so
I have my slug working that's helpful
anyone see it yet and I'm I'm lost I I
think they should be working first pose
second post I'm not quite sure okay yeah
just give me a give me a second while I
figure this out but in general the the
plugins are that if are the hardest part
of Gatsby which is why I should have
prepped for this more okay you know why
because I think I changed the name of
all the thing from slug to post I
shouldn't have done that I like to I
like to call it slug rather than 400
never mind sorry sorry sorry sorry I'm
fixing interesting I'm just gonna remove
all mention of slug because it used to
work before and then I intelligently
will change things I've asked me to
don't do that
so
still gonna be fun better know
if anyone if anyone's experience it gets
me and see something wrong please shout
out the answer because I'm a bit lost
yeah
anything
yeah so the pace curry I I can I can get
the exact thing that I want I'm just
running the quarry this this should be
in the query it's not no so that means
that I'm getting the wrong info here
yeah yeah okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna
bring up the docs for page Corey sorry I
just like configure the wrong thing
feel free to read like the rest of gassy
plugins so I'm gonna figure this out
don't worry to be sick that's be great
fortunately the docs are pretty pretty
handy so there's a way to have the input
ah
that isn't even Paul
so sorry no I'm still figuring it out if
anyone knows what's going on let me know
what do you mean did I doubt did I not
do that
be honest I think context is for other
stuff
give me a sec
yeah yes
stupid SEO yeah we need a past context
what am i passing context path one line
okay well that was super annoying you
needed to pass context into the path so
basically inside of gatsby node we have
that string we need to pass the string
so that it can be the source of that
query for the page template to query
things with TI l right TI oh so now we
have a different error that's progress
I think I just need to refresh huh
okay shoot what's up in order to show
that yeah let me just refresh to confirm
that I am completely [ __ ] okay oh okay
oh look look at this that's a cache
error this happens so sometimes the
cache invalidation fails because you're
making some edits that are that are off
of Gatsby node I need to just delete the
cache and we run again huh yeah that's
that's one of the problems that people
experience I guess you will understand
is cache invalidation is hard it's still
it's still not okay you think yeah I
changed it from slowly it's locked
okay so let's change it back to slug
they start from the caffeine oh I didn't
mess up anything like with the end
people yeah that's my fault
okay so I guess we know yeah
if one is needed to be a slob
yeah I know I just changed it around
because I thought that I didn't want to
confuse the things and then the other
clear finish and singing I'm not really
sure but I am looking into the doc you
needed to sing the part you think that's
it and oh there's no slug here man I
hate JavaScript look how many dudes
touch good thank you
yeah I've run into this kind of thing a
lot and it does it does it does really
suck
I swear no gasp you guys but the idea
the idea is there right like hopefully I
brought you through the process of
consume transform and then I have a
template and then you inside of Gatsby
nodejs programmatically run through and
generate there's a lot of little pieces
and things can go wrong and you have to
be careful it doesn't throw an error for
example just now one of my mistakes one
of my mistakes I'm gonna I'm gonna push
this as well so you can just get pull
[Music]
like my commit log is just fix fix fix
fix fix
okay you can get Paul now but but but
basically one of my mistakes if I didn't
have a variable called slug defined here
and I just I just said slug I tried to
be fancy or I try try to be es6 and I
just did slug slug is not defined and it
didn't - an error that's that's going to
be fixed like there there
they're working on the error messages
you just have to be aware of it
especially cuz you're not working in any
sort of type checking system that these
these kinds of things might pop up just
be very careful what you're what you're
wiring together again they're plugins so
what we're doing right is we're actually
writing a small plugin for ourselves
gets this this every plugin has access
to the same api the create pages api the
create an own api on create page life
cycle hook all these things can be
bundled up into a plugin so if I wrote
this plug-in I can publish it on NPM you
can install it and it will be
automatically run for you so you don't
have to code this this is low-level
custom code that's why it's so funky and
weird because you can do whatever you
want right but the goal is to take take
this low-level API build on top of it
with plugins and we plugins build on top
of that with beams so I mean we're
eventually gonna go there so I'm very
behind but yeah so I want you to get to
this left gets this stage have some
navigation if you want to have a blog
index like with all the markdown files
go ahead and do that if you're feeling
adventurous go ahead and do the image
plug-in install the image transformation
I have a ghastly 3a the Gatsby image
docks I don't expect to cover this here
but I'll definitely go try it out on
your own just to give you an intuition
of why you want to use Gatsby image this
images are one of the big performance
bottlenecks in a site typically like
even my company head is guilty of doing
this that we will publish like a
super-fast site but then a two megabyte
image right there no one no one no one
needs
so what guess we image does is it
transforms resize this and and serves
the right one based on on your on your
client and and it has these nice
progressive loading features so this is
the blob effect let me refresh you see
that blur you see that blur it's sorry
so it just shows that blur in an inline
SVG and then once the image loads it
just replaced with hot swaps
I like this along the background color
one just fades in very nice
tres SVG shows the trace and then it
fades in right these are all pre
processing stages we have a source image
file transform create all this like
random crap and then and then have got
to be image serve it for you
web P I don't know what there's just
whatever but yeah so there is a [ __ ] ton
of functionality stuffed in here
basically all to make your user
experience fast but it also looks nice I
think that's very impressive I think
it's it's I seen it used in a bunch of
e-commerce sites I do want to give you
some inspiration so if anyone knows of
Harry's the razor startup they actually
started they actually launched their
female brand this is the gatsby site and
it stores you can see this this fading
effect that's also progressive loading
you can tell if something else itís
guess we are not with this chrome
plug-in
it just shows it just shows a purple G
yeah it's also it's a react site it's
not another fight site I don't know I
have I have a bunch of these just
sniffing headers but you can actually
look at the elements and just go like
that's V you can see oh generator gets
me 2.0 so so you know like there are
there are a whole bunch of examples oh I
should also give you okay I'm really bad
at this
that's why this is not my full-time job
but here's the here's an example of size
you can build good gatsby I should have
sparked it with this they'll react GS
Doc's isn't Gatsby you can clone it and
and look at look at what's in there
Airbnb is data science blog impossible
foods the the fake meat the vegetarian
eating bran calm is on Gatsby there's a
there's a whole bunch of stuff it's
mostly static sites are mostly marketing
sites but increasingly you're going to
get dynamic applications as well so
let's see if there's any API sites oh
this is more for like SendGrid and okay
so yeah well we're gonna get to that
part in the service section I just want
you to go through the
that I just went through and we have 20
minutes for that I'll say I'll set some
timers and we'll reconvene at 3:30 okay
all right thank you
[Applause]
yeah thanks nice way for that I think I
think one of the purposes that I had you
clone all those sites is I really wanted
to look at those the source codes for
those things and I've given you the
rough framework to understand what's
going on in there it's a lot of node
it's a lot of graph QL makes inside of
node it's a lot of like is this
undefined yeah all right let's go fix
that but just keep in mind it's
low-level stuff and we will build we'll
build up over time and we'll just start
using each other's plugins and and all
that in fact I really want you to look
at plug-in source code as well this is a
really good exercise to understand that
there's no magic so just pick any random
plug-in I'm gonna pick a source plug-in
let's just call it Shopify gasps we saw
Shopify okay it's an official plug-in
I'm gonna view plug-in on github so this
is maintained by the Gaspee team inside
of here it's got some readme it's got
some package JSON nothing much like it
can install its own dependencies right
and inside of the source code what do
you have it's got to be no js' it's the
thing that you just wrote so essentially
it's just nested gasps three projects
nesting nesting nesting in in and off
itself every plugin can basically just
run this code for you but when when
you're a user you just use it as gasps
resource stop if I there's a lot more
ApS than we did not cover but definitely
just get a sense of what these what
plugins are just presets of things that
you already you could write yourself but
you only write it as a last resort or
because you know people haven't written
the thing that you want it to write okay
so
where we get Jeff stacked so we should
be at for gatsby themes okay so this is
a very short one because it's a it's a
feature that has not been released yet
but it's the biggest thing that is ever
happened to Gatsby and I would not be
doing my my job right if I do not tell
you about it at least
so plugins on steroids so plugins can
can implement Gatsby nodejs
yes we browser yes we config you ask
SPSS or yes those are all the individual
API is for different modes of rendering
from the SSR side to the browser side
what gasps three themes do is their
plugins plus presets of components so
they ship for you so there's there's a
bunch of reading that you can do I'm
just gonna show you the theme that I've
been working on this is the source code
for that theme and I want to see only to
see how that's how little code that is
like I intentionally structured it this
way because you I want you to feel the
existing pain of the low-level code and
I demoed it for you myself
not on purpose
so this is a site this is how it looks
in and as a deployed site and typically
you'd have to have a whole bunch of code
just to make a site like this right
again it's reading from it's it's it's
applying syntax highlighting to code
it's that it has you know the emoji
stuff and it's got an overwritten
component so the source code for this is
literally just gatsby config guess I
have my site metadata and then I have a
theme that's it I don't have anything
else I have no page generation : oh the
stuff that I modeled through earlier
that's fine that could be a plug-in what
separates it from a theme is that my
source slash pages actually it's not the
pages that's just a components I only
have one thing
there's the only that's the only
component that I have because I've
overwritten this vital component this is
the bio component everything else comes
from the theme so let's look at the
source code of the theme itself so this
is Gabbie theme dev blog demo that's
okay Gatsby themed their blog so inside
this theme I have basically clones Danny
whoa mobs site and I included all the
source components it's got a whole bunch
of them right layout whatever and I said
alright I only want to overwrite or
shadow the bio component the bio
component this is the source side right
this is the bio component I'd say I want
to replace it with my own right so the
only thing I have to only they have to
specify is my own bio component source
components slash Bible is and I can
write whatever I want I put my name in
there
because I can take credit for it but but
you see you see that you see that the
theme potential that by default I
install and I can get layout I can get
panel I can get the SEO element and it
all just ships with my theme so it's a
plugin on steroids
the goal for gets me what the gallery
team told me is that you're the ghost
for you to be able to install them side
by side so right now I have my gatsby
config I have only one theme here but
what if you can install a ecommerce
theme alongside your blog alongside your
marketing site and then it's just all
composers together nicely I think right
now that is a pipe dream because all
these things are completely unspecified
where where things clash so we're all
gonna have to get together as a
community to decide what the standards
are because these all the Gatsby's doing
is providing the under-underground on
the underlying tools but this is a
really good open source opportunity for
us to build the next WordPress by saying
installable themes and and then and then
the only thing you're responsible for
its content fine so so I just want to
study the sell you on the idea of themes
we're not going to
time to implement it I think it's I have
some videos they have some videos go
through the docs and wait for the
official launch I think it's in one or
two months but that's the Gatsby theme
section any questions about themes like
if you wanted to do anything
but yeah I I feel like I feel like I've
hyped it up enough okay yeah yeah so so
if you see how the shadowing works to
avoid so let's say I'm shadowing this
theme I have I have the name of the
theme that I'm shadowing slash
components so if I have multiple themes
installed it won't clash yeah
and so the yeah the only thing though I
think I'm specifying it's just my
content right so this is an extremely
light vlog like the only thing I mean
stuff I have like one dependency I have
I've got to be I have reacted react arm
and gets me in that blog that's it for
dependencies right so pretty pretty
bright future for fur Gatsby I'm sorry
about all the low-level stuff and I made
you go through that because that's the
that's what we have right all this stuff
that's the underlying system but if you
think that this has a feature then let's
build on top of it and and and just make
it make life easier for everyone okay so
so we're more or less done with Gatsby
there was a whirlwind intro one thing I
one thing I'm really proud of is that I
actually went through the source code of
the Gatsby lifecycle method so in detail
what each API does what each lifecycle
hook is you have the links for this in
gatsby lifecycle MB over here if you
really want to know which what API is
you can take advantage of and what what
opportunities there are for you know
building cool cool stuff definitely read
like the the process of how Gatsby works
internally I just don't have time
to do that here but I'm the guy that
wrote the docs so ask me anything you
know it looks a little bit nicer now
it's just super worthy because like we
have to like talk to everyone
it's make everyone happy I'd rather just
make myself happy so all right so okay
so so now we're gonna talk about service
and then and and that's pretty much all
we have time for together today so this
is slightly like gasps resolves
what does gasps be solved gets resolved
perfect right like it it it's
data-driven documents as much as react
is a function of data and it you you put
data into react I think I'll put an app
Gatsby lets you put in data in an
upwards of site and generates all those
HTML files what it doesn't do is all the
servers the the responsibilities of a
server like executing code so that's
like that's why Jam stack and service
are very good pairs of each other
because everything I just I cannot do a
server list should be able to do so
we're gonna go through a small
presentation this is not my presentation
but I strongly believe in it and this
will give you a pretty solid
understanding of service this buzzword
that everyone is talking about mainly
don't expect it to do everything yet but
every single year things get easier and
easier and easier
we used to worry about cold start
problems we don't anymore and anything
you hear about co-starred is probably
wrong those talk to the cloud fair
workers people they start in eight
milliseconds it's insane so so this
isn't in an area of intense research and
that's that's why we wanted to talk
about it today all right let's see if I
can pull up this slides slide URLs there
you have the link as well so don't don't
don't worry about it
let's talk a little bit about why
services again talking about the lamp of
slash mean model
imagine you have an app where it like
hits a cup of hacker news and it just
gets a billion points right so although
all things just all people in the world
come to your things and they're just
streaming in like massive traffic and at
some level scale if you have a server
you're you're fine and it's a very
simple programming model with more you
start sweating a bit and then with
extreme amounts your service starts
catching fire and at some point it will
just go down there get the hug of death
or the slash dotted or whatever or the
reddit hug the death depending on what
generation you grew up in Chrome I don't
the chrome can run on a memory I don't
know about this site this is not my
science but like the point is like web
architecture is as convoluted as
convoluted as it is if we're going to
reconstitute this we actually have to
come out of a different architecture
that's event-driven so we're gonna we're
going to come to that in a bit
service at its core the reason you want
to adopt service auto-scaling
paper execution third-party services
like third party API is right and you
focus on business logic not like scaling
up and scaling down your your servers as
well as event-driven workflows so this
is the this is the key part to
understand that anything that you used
to do on the server you can probably do
with a web hook here and a callback to
that web hook there that's about it
that's that's it's a rough idea
especially cron jobs a lot of people
don't understand that cron jobs are free
basically because you can call like a
web cast on Io give it an end point and
we're just ping it on a regular basis if
it responds oh okay but like Ron dot IO
con job org basically if you need
recurring services is also do it's also
doable without a server you don't need a
server to like set aside an infinite
loop or something you can just literally
ping an API and you put all your
business logic in that API and let it
execute
okay so in other words like you want
service to be extracted away from the
developer you're writing just the
business logic and I really like this
micro building thing because obviously
you're not I don't want to pay like you
know that standard five dollar thing for
like if I'm not using it I'm not using
it and I should have to worry about it
at all it actually is is there's a huge
ecosystem I think that a lot of people
only talk about AWS but actually there's
you know IBM bluemix is pretty
interesting
I think like there there's some there's
some up-and-coming names I think begin
is a very very interesting service
platform for people to explore and
obviously nullify the company I work at
service is not a so there's like two
competing terms like function as a
service and service so there's actually
the the sexier term because it's the one
that pisses people off more so the
people just talk about it it's a really
good talk III like like what if you you
didn't learn the server full method from
the beginning and you start it from
service and and and focus on the mindset
that you're trying to work on business
problems and not like the the
infrastructural scaling issues that a
lot of people have to deal with so what
can you do what can you do what can you
do a service anything with asterisks
which is basically long-running jobs if
you have a long-running process like a
machine learning job you probably want
to stick that in a server somewhere so
functions as of right now functions must
complete execution in under 15 minutes
that used to be five minutes that used
to be ten seconds even earlier as just
gets longer and longer and now with like
step functions in it obvious lambda you
can actually chop things up and execute
them in in sequence and in batches so
who's using service all these guys
I like Coca Cola yeah like the the stuff
the big of people that you'd think New
York Public Library actually so I do a
lot of meetups with them and they're
surprisingly advanced basically they
have redefined themselves to be a
digital library so they serve like three
times more people online than they serve
in in person so they are definitely a
tech company whatever a lot of people
it's fine so how do you how do you get
server this choose your cloud you pick
your deployment to deployment tool can
come most of us most of us the this like
second layer there's what they call
second layer cloud providers can compile
to the the first layer so it's it's
regarded as like the first layer of
cloud is like hard the hardware layer
and then the second layer card is
software layer this can be for multiple
reasons like portability among them
there's a framework called service the
service framework service calm it's not
the same as service in general it's just
very good SEO so yeah they just bought
service comm and now they get everything
ok so yeah I already told you about the
ecosystem I think I think one skill to
learn is that you should understand that
instead of having a server where all the
pieces are computing just came with it
like you had a hard disk you had to some
memory you had you had a running time
now in a service environment all the
parts of compute are broken up so you
have functions for compute you have
storage like like your file blobs and
stuff your databases that are separate
API is these are all separate API is
even a state machine
I think it's connect Kinesis anyone to
use Canisius yeah I don't use it but I
was surprised that you can have a state
machine as a as a service I don't know I
don't I don't use it at all so I'm just
repeating other people's words for them
this we even have specialized tooling to
like connect your Lego blocks together
the stuff that you don't have to use and
that's an S call craft Co that's why
that's where you get all these like
charts that are very common in the
industry so like for example spinning up
a REST API you can actually just model a
REST API as an API gateway it resolves
to several different lambda functions
and if you need persistence they can
they can be backing the they can have
you can stay
DynamoDB behind the graphical API
basically just one more layer in front
of your resolvers your visual ways are
now your lambda functions as well so I
pretty I like that a lot especially with
Apollo Federation the new thing that
they just launched it's very easy to
break up your graphical schemas web hug
listeners same thing really it's just
that it's web hooks are ways for when
when you have a when you have a job to
execute you fire off the job it executes
web books our way for them to call back
with the with the completed information
and it tells you that that your
completed so again now you don't need a
running instance authentication is a
pain point for surf or surveillance
because a lot of times you need a
running session on the server side to do
authentication and a lot of people lose
that model when you when you go serve
this because everything has to be
stateless especially when you're when
you're trying to execute in a
distributed fashion if this if this
tributed execution is not a concern to
you which is not concerned in most
people then it's no issue at all you can
you can just call back to a database but
yeah it's a lot of calling back like
calling to the off provider already
calls back to you you confirm you that
with that particular token and now
you're allowed to execute something so
this there's that's the difference
between off two and OAuth one that
there's there's support for that for
these kinds of workflows yeah that's
what this is the Kinesis thing I which I
which I don't I don't understand as like
all right you could ingest a lot of
things and then so what but apparently
you can fire off different events based
on the state of here yeah yeah I've
never set this up but I think I think
you have to be in like the millions of
traffic to to be able to start needing
this whereas I'm more of a hackathon
kind of guy let's see yeah abusing so
good because you can scale up in
parallel all these functions at once you
can all send them to a singles endpoint
we can actually use it as low testing
which is what Nordstrom did for
themselves ahead of their big sales
sales days that they call it service
artillery and you can go check it out
which is true right like you I actually
met this serverless user in LA he told
me that he has a ecommerce startup and
95% of his traffic comes on four days of
the year so what yeah there's no there's
no server like the traditional server
model doesn't really apply there so form
handling okay I'm like drowning you and
all these use cases to really show that
people have worked out the the
architecture it's new it's alien it's
hard but it will get easier every single
year and the fundamental simplicity and
the cost model should be compelling
enough for those who want to try it for
for gem stack there's no option you you
have to use service to to execute
everything else so I think I think
that's the that's the rough pitch
I actually I personally really like
serve this framework it's a single yamo
file where you can provision like a
single llamó config file we can
provision like a service function a
database anything that you might need as
one single piece of code and then send
it and deploy it so it it has that git
commit and get git flow workflow with it
so so you can roll back and and
reprovision as much as easily as you can
so yeah I mean you can you can based on
that you can provision anything like a
cron job infrastructure stuff rest
endpoints I just really like the
flexibility of service framework the
cost is cost calculators and you can
model them as as such so here one of our
one of our Mike my coworker side
projects is has a thousand daily active
users 20 API calls the day it cost him
six dollars a month and it scales up and
down whenever whenever he wants so
that's that's super nice so yeah that's
the that's the overall pitch I think
that it's very it's very raw like in
terms of like what I can present to you
because it's highly dependent on the
platform in the provider I'm trying to
give a general intro for anyone who
hasn't really had that introduction to
service so let's let's
jump back to to the slides I really like
so if you want a real sales pitch
check out this talk by the VP of AWS
lambda and AWS reinvent talking about
all the different use cases from from
real folks and and just like the pace of
acceleration if you're worried about
lock-in the cost of execution only goes
down in an AWS lehand so so that's
pretty I mean it's a pretty sweet stack
to make projects with and and eventually
you know if you're if you're a service
native company I think I think that's
that's probably a good bet
long term okay examples of apps you can
build with gatsby's so gatsby press
service here are some I don't I don't
have a lot mainly because they're not
open source so I only focused on open
source ones a lot of these are closed
source because there are actual
companies the gatsby store when you are
contributor to get free as an open
source contributor they immediately send
you a token and you can redeem it for
swag and and it's all it's all done on
this on this store it's an e-commerce
store
I've already claimed a bunch of [ __ ] I
can log in write this this breaks your
model of a static site like this looks
like an app this looks like there's a
server behind this there's no server
it's gonna it's pulling out my details
it's checking my contributions to Gatsby
it no it's no longer giving me any
discount codes because I cleaned
everything it checks it checks the SKU
use choose the size it has an order card
this is dynamic AF and and and you know
thousands people use this they have they
have more demos obviously like you know
this these are this is open source so
you can actually check it out and and
you should contribute to Gatsby because
now you know you have the basic
knowledge to do it but obviously the my
go-to
my go-to example is shell flamingo where
they're actually trading dollars for for
actual products and it's a real startup
gatsby mail is a pretty interesting one
I don't
no if I can login I don't think I can
login so this is my actual meal so don't
hack me [ __ ]
what else can I login with I might be
able to just jeez okay I think I think
the the token for this expired but do I
have a video
no okay anyway email clients built as a
Gatsby app just like super server this
okay like because and again and again I
want to make that comparison like a lot
of some people I really like this but it
doesn't appeal to everyone we have an
existential war between the web and
closed platforms like and and it was it
was it and so mobile platforms are
winning because a lot of people spend
their time on mobile right like they
want needed the native app experience if
we can build rich clients that load
quickly we have we win a lot of that
that battle and then we are on the
feature parity in terms of access to AP
is and executing stuff we can do exactly
the same things so really it's the we
need to work on the delivery mechanism
for delivering mobile clients that are
just as good as like app store clients
right from the Apple App Store Google
Play Store just as good but way thinner
because they're their websites right so
we don't we don't have like the 500
megabytes that the Facebook dog Facebook
app takes up we just have 137 kilobytes
so so we need to we need to engineer our
way into into that by code splitting by
by doing all the the performance stuff
that gets we gets gets you okay that's a
lot of me talking so the the really
stupid reach goal for me was to get you
to to try out amplify CLI so if you if
you want to go ahead this is for people
who want to massive AWS and some of you
cannot so your freedom massive nullify
as well know if I say alright but if you
follow these instructions
options.this this is the remainder of
the workshop you're free to go here and
we are near 4:30 anyway we have half an
hour but I'm gonna stay here I'm gonna
help you through this
basically a lotus amplify is all the
services or AWS put in your CLI and it's
very easy it's just running one command
to configure it so I have here
instructions to set up in AWS amplify
for an existing project you can amplify
add off storage functions API analytics
hosting notification interactions and
there's more coming
I think they just added video streaming
the other day so you can do like HQ
trivia I don't know if you have that
here anyway so adding authentication
amplify add off and in the template that
I give you and now in the in the repo
you literally just switched it off off
versions of all the off layout off
header off whatever that's already and
your github repo and then once you're
done
always remember to amplify push whatever
you're done configuring new capability
always amplify push so we have this for
service authentication we have this for
server let's compute with AWS lambda you
write your lambda functions we have this
for service storage if you're storing
images if you're storing
for blobs and stuff like that and at the
end of this I think that at home you can
make an instant Instagram clone with all
this functionality using using gatsby
using this material UI theme right this
is all that's all you need
yeah you got Gatsby you got this
material UI theme you got the service
storage this is going to be super
important service storage of the files
and you can display the images yeah and
then and then authentication for for
people who need to authenticate into
their accounts so this is this is the
homework this is the you if you want to
get if you want to like make money with
service you want to make money with
genocide I think I mean this is this is
where to learn it has never been easier
like no one no one no one works at AWS
like this right it's usually like
suffering through a whole bunch of like
walkthroughs on the site now it's all in
the CLI no there's a guy that
walkthrough
and a very dedicated dev team and they
have they have helper libraries so okay
look at look at how I access my
authentication you see here they've
written all the helper libraries you
don't need to do anything you just
import off from AWS - FFI slash off [ __ ]
right and then off the car not an
authenticated user set user or whatever
that's it that's stupid simple so I
really like this for API is you
literally API dog yet the name of the
API and that calls it right so storage
okay
storage dog get you're not even like
you're not even copying pasting the the
a RN or whatever whatever you have API
this is service function API API don't
get they just wrap it they just wrap it
for you so you don't access the direct
URL so that's so that's different from
the other fine yeah yeah so everyone has
this Google has something similar and
I'll if I have something similar
services so I think it'll us probably is
ahead by the most because they have a
thousand people on this thing and
they're they're dead set on making all
of AWS into this new paradigm of
literally run a single command to add
that functionality answer a few
questions and you're done so I encourage
you to try it out that's the remainder
of this workshop and try encourage you
to try out together with Gatsby and
obviously feel free to ping me on
Twitter or github with questions yeah
okay um enjoy
thank you thank you yeah I'm gonna put
on music but I'll be around raise your
hand if you need help